non messieurs bonsoir on sait peu de
choses encore du grave accident
nucléaire qui s'est produit à la
centrale de tchernobyl
la situation s'est détériorée à la
centrale de fukushima il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétude par rapport au nucléaire
le 4 mars 2022 le monde a retenu son
souffle alors que ce faisceau lumineux
tombé du ciel la centrale nucléaire de
zaporijia la plus grande d'europe est
alors attaqué par un missile russe
heureusement les réacteurs ne sont pas
touchés
le bâtiment administratif lui et qu'elle
signer dès
[Musique]
le club en place pour les compromis
puis le 24 février l'armée russe a pillé
et occupé pendant plus d'un mois la
centrale désaffectée de tchernobyl et la
zone d'exclusion de rayon de 30
kilomètres qui fortement contaminée
pourtant rappelle ce spécialiste
français le protocole de genève est
clair qu'on doit selon le droit
international ces sites sont totalement
protégé leur interdit de les cibler à la
lumière des récents événements et des
risques liés aux catastrophes naturelles
il ya matière à relancer le débat sur la
sécurité nucléaire selon certains
spécialistes en ukraine on 15 réacteurs
qui étaient en fonctionnement
des grands réacteurs avec des
inventaires de radioactivité incroyable
toutes les règles d'exploitation sont
sont violés il n'y a aujourd'hui plus
plus de règles aux faits surtout qu'au
nom de l'urgence climatique
plusieurs pays dont le canada veut miser
sur l'énergie nucléaire car la
production de cette énergie et mais très
peu de gaz à effet de serre au canada on
compte déjà 19 réacteurs répartis dans
quatre centrales nucléaires trois
d'entre elles sont en ontario et l'autre
est au nouveau brunswick à la commission
canadienne de sûreté nucléaire qui
chapeaute la réglementation des
centrales on assure que les sites
nucléaires sont très bien protégées de
niveau de protection existent et la
sûreté des systèmes et la sécurité
physique des sites la super c'est
vraiment de s'assurer que tous les
systèmes mise en place ponsot
bien fonctionne de façon indépendante si
jamais un système ne fonctionnait pas un
autre système pourra prendre la relève
quant à la sécurité physique des
installations la commission affirme que
le coeur des réacteurs sont contenues
dans de très gros presto cylindrique en
acier qui peuvent supporter d'immenses
pressions les centrales elles sont
recouvertes d'un bouclier de ciment
capable de résister à toute sorte
d'attaqué
puis les plans d'intervention d'urgence
ont revue annuellement ils doivent
répondre à des exigences de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
certaines mesures exigées et inclut la
capacité
mais plusieurs experts affirment que ces
systèmes de sûreté et de sécurité ne
sont pas sans faille surtout s'il y est
à manquer d'électricité pendant une
période prolongée une partie dont
l'énergie nucléaire ou du jouet me
regarder le réacteur il est protégé par
des murs en remet une couche de béton
brut mais ce n'est pas le cas justement
des piscines de refroidissement qu elles
sont vulnérables à des accidents à des
attaques de bus terroristes des
explosions dans ces piscines reposent
des barres de combustibles usés qui
doivent être constamment refroidi le cas
de l'accident nucléaire de fukushima en
2011 au japon en est un exemple concret
le séisme a détruit tous les systèmes de
secours rendant impossible le
refroidissement les barres de
combustible ont donc explosé et cousez
décontamination massives en cas de
conflit il est aussi possible que des
malfaiteurs vol des déchets radioactifs
pour en faire des armes
guy marleau professeur en génie physique
croit que le développement de l'énergie
nucléaire peut se faire en toute
sécurité on est deux jours dans le
mouvement va une sécurité améliorée
une réduction des déchets et des
nouveaux réacteurs qui sont maintenant
présentées pour l'industrie sont
beaucoup plus sécuritaire que les
anciens réacteurs les détracteurs de
l'atome affirme qu'il existe aujourd'hui
des options beaucoup moins coûteuse et
plus verte que l'énergie nucléaire et
surtout ils s'opposent aux discours
vantant son côté sécuritaire car s'il
est vrai que les accidents du caire
restera lorsqu'ils surviennent une costa
être dévastateur ici elisa céret radio
canada montréal